there are two events in my lifetime that
our markers in that respect I was um
then my loft on this southern end of
green street when Martin Luther King was
assassinated this was 68 and soho was
not soho yet and which is rags and rats
and the real street lights and they're
only like 20 people who lived between
canal street and houston street and saw
my wife was it aloft at the other end of
the of green and houston so i left my
loft at the canal street and started
walking towards houston and as I was
walking the street was very dark there
were almost no lights saw a man
approached me a big man and he was sort
of lumbering along working quite fast
and all of a sudden he came into a light
of street light and I saw the man look
at me black man and I saw him look at me
and is the first time that I ever felt
that a black man hated me just because I
was white I hadn't had anything to do
with Martin Luther King dying but I was
being held responsible and I absolutely
understand that and that was a sea
change in America and I just find it so
moving that from 68 well now in my
lifetime I was able to see this change
and the see America embrace black men
very moving
I was at Yale graduate school and
Malcolm X was standing on the corner
handing out leaflets and he's easy to
recognize because he had red hair I mean
the only black man with red hair you've
ever seen and it was not tied it was
actually written and you know I went up
to him and I the good white liberal boy
you know I said you know what can I do
and he said get out of the way